if this landscape were as onra of music
what would the genre be cracky
I don't know probably that the bagpipes
you know of Scotland its kind of radio
rock its kind of smooth its kind of flat
yeah I mean I immediately think of the
Eagles Maori thrash an existing genre of
music it is now
[Applause]
[Applause]
a teenaged heavy metal band from
Northland has made history by winning
both the smoke-free Rock quest and the
smoke-free Pacifica beats competition on
the same weekend the members of alien
weaponry brothers Henry and Lewis too
young
along with faced by Ethan tremble and
pressed the rock quest judges with being
using
[Music]
yo we just on the top of the road tuning
it now do you think right we've been a
band for eight years and I mean really
we've been playing shows since I was
probably about 13 it would be strange to
not have our parents on on the road with
us all the time we work really well as a
team and this would not have been
possible without our family like
honestly it's it's really amazing what
they've done in order to make this
happen for us yeah I mean there was that
I still don't really like their like
real black death metal stuff it's like a
brick wall of sound you know yeah I
think mum likes our music I mean she she
puts up with it at least
[Music]
how old were you guys when you wrote
your first song Oh God
I was 10 and Louis was 8 when we wrote
our first song it's early afternoon
Azalea memory yeah
[Music]
[Music]
so these guys are like your brothers you
sort of been adopted by the family right
yeah he's at our house often enough that
you know he may as well be our brother
I met Luis at primary school but we sort
of got to know each other at circus
school and waipu called circle circus
and um one day we're in the band room
and Henry and Luis are jamming out and
Neil was passing around the base just
sort of trying it out turns out I was
the only kid that could actually reach
you into the base so by default I sort
of became the bass player so I guess
you're like yeah
when we were younger we'd go on road
trips with mom and dad and dad used to
be constantly pointing out landmarks and
stuff and then you know saying hey boys
you know what bishal happened here and
then you know of course we wouldn't know
and so he'd go on to explain the story
Maori history is fascinating there's all
sorts of interesting and bizarre things
that have happened here
[Applause]
[Music]
despo he is one of the main PO out of
the house at 80 which is the neighboring
house to our folly Nui home ate a fatty
so um this was carved by to whittle he
was one of our family as well not a lot
of kids have a father who actually knows
pretty much everything about the
genealogy all the way down to our
ancestors who landed here you know
thousands of years ago
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Hakka is what you guys would refer to as
the war dance so you know it's what you
do to your enemy to intimidate them and
scare them and kind of prove yourself
before a battle
yeah well it's it's a very aggressive
with the idea of really getting the
performance almost enraged and ready for
battle now Adam Blair with the hawk up
for New Zealand
[Applause]
a lot of performers and stuff we'll try
to kind of modernize the traditional
Maori performance style it's quite a
aggressive performance so really the the
Mitchell and the haka really fit really
well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Hucker is not always done as a as a war
challenge it's often done as a way of
identifying who you are it's a way of
showing support and powerful emotion to
other people dad's very connected with
our Maori side of the family because me
and Louis had grown up speaking Maori we
decided that it would be a good idea to
maybe incorporate that into our music
[Music]
and we've had a few people come up to us
at gigs and tell us hey I've started
taking multi classes because of you guys
and it's really cool
I have a lot of Dutch in me which is why
I'm quite white I identify more as Maori
because that's just as I was growing up
that's really what I connected most with
my dad used to do Hucker with a guy who
was entirely Dutch 100% Dutch and this
guy used to get asked all the time you
know why do you do this why don't you do
something that's more Dutch he used to
say to people have you ever seen Dutch
folk dancing why would I want to do that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we just went into the Hobbit and a bunch
which the second movie said that was
built for the Rings fruity for The
Hobbit trilogy and we had fruitful hard
holes
amazing little village get all balled
around us get to walk along the paths
and Frodo and Gandalf dead in the films
now looking out to the right that's the
view that Peter Jackson envisioned the
Shire to look like rolling green hills
with any River Valley scattered tree
lines and in the distance you got the
added bonus of the highway Rangers which
did Beach in the Fellowship of the Ring
for like five seconds
when you guys suggested filming
something in Hobbiton our immediate
reaction was kind of a very strong no um
I suppose we didn't want to be confused
with Dungeons & Dragons sorcery wizard
on the mountain metal there's lots of
bands had actually planned their genre
and and they all of their songs are very
heroic they're about you know wizards on
mountains and Kings on horses and sword
fighting
[Music]
the boys felt that their music was about
real-life stuff it's not fantasy metal
they are more in touch with and aware of
the kind of socio-political climate of
the world
for us one of the reasons we started
writing was to inspire people to relearn
the language there was actually a point
in New Zealand history where the
language was actually banned in schools
and you could get into a lot of trouble
for speaking Maori or even being Maori
tempers flare today as hundreds marched
on the Parliament grounds about 600
people joined EU leaders from the far
north or Auckland in Poe donor to
protest over the issue of overlapping
treaty claims we are fighting for
everyone who has been ripped off by
colonial government it's one of the main
sources of tension and frustration and
multi community here so what's the point
of this film just about collaboration is
about teamwork there's just about the
family coming together there's this
about meeting their goals what is the
message and points of this film I was
actually on the bus coming home from
school and Neil calls me up any psychic
would you like to open for profesor age
at Spa Kirino is like yeah and like I
sort of had to take well for it to sink
in and then I'll say sir I just cried
you get some machine in public into me
right yeah it's just like it's been
quite overwhelming how fast everything
has been moving I mean of course one of
the early influences for the band was
Rage Against the Machine so for them
it's a bit of a dream come true now to
actually open for the prophets of rage
you know eggs and ham dirt we are just
leaving counts now so we'll see you in
probably about 20 is about 25 minutes
double time dear now we got this message
from the high school saying Lois has not
showed up at school today was it like a
truancy notice my just got a truancy
noticed it was fall for you to us
objects saying you're absent Lois is
absent where is he I'm not sure we're
the loading dock sir so that I can see
loading docks there I don't know how we
get there we might have to get off a
different Road so you want to pull out
the Eoin right it's behind this car okay
we're moving now guys
[Music]
hello I'll agree remedy now here
anything upon exit stage and I think
closest yet how you feeling this good
see people came running to the front of
the stage as soon as the doors were open
kind of cold as you guys grow and bigger
just always remember waiting come and
that don't keep you grounded
[Applause]
right before we play this song I just
want to thank offensive rage from
wanting us to play with them we grew up
on Rage Against the Machine a public
enemy has been a dream come true for us
but I especially want to thank you guys
for showing up and watching us we love
you more than anyone the song is
dedicated to our great great great
grandfather who fought at the ballet
kata his name
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
part of what we're doing is we're
putting you know our history into these
souls one of our songs that Tiffany was
actually about our ancestor who died at
Gate Park which was a real big battle
that happened during the mid-1800s we
pay our whoa who is my great
grandfather's grandfather was killed it
a lot of my family fought in that battle
so it does hold a personal connection to
us
[Music]
it's been really cool to be able to
actually get crowds that are really
insanely into what we are doing in and
moshing really really really hard to
music
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you already wet the drain you guys
made us in the first table of ten
minutes all right
we love each and every one of him good
night it's getting to the point now
where I think any speaker was gonna have
to be an unmarked vehicle just because
we are stopped so often now for
photographs and things that yeah that's
in order to get to where we're going you
may have to do it in disguise
[Music]
what's the next step for the band I
don't know well we'll head off to Europe
see care for chains I suppose hail the
new wave of destruction
[Music]
[Music]